a conditional statement is an if-then
statement if blank happens then blank
will happen for example if you study
your math then you'll get a good grade
okay now what the Congress is it's you
switch the to the hypothesis and the
conclusion whatever comes after the if
is the hypothesis whatever comes after
the then is the conclusion but when you
switch those we call this the converse
now if the conditional statement is true
and the converse statement is also true
the way I like to think about it is if
you say it forwards and then in reverse
or backwards the Congress if they're
both true both those statements then
that means you can write it as a by
conditional statement by meaning to
conditional meaning if then okay and we
can symbolize this with a double arrow
so if P if and only if Q or Q if and
only if P and that's how you want to
write your by conditional statement what
you do is if it's true forwards and
reverse meaning the conditional and
Congress are both true you drop the if
and you replace the then with this
phrase if and only if okay and so what
that does is it tells the reader meaning
you and me that it's true for words and
in Reverse let's do an example so if a
triangle has an angle measure that's
greater than 90 degrees then it is an
obtuse triangle so just a quick visual
here say you have a triangle and this
angle is 120 degrees then we would call
this triangle an obtuse triangle right
okay but now here's the thing whatever
comes after the if okay meaning a
triangle has an angle manager greater
than 90 that's our hypothesis whatever
comes after the then that's our
conclusion right so is this true if a
triangle has an angle measure greater
than 90 then it's an obtuse triangle yes
that's true but now what we're gonna do
is want to switch the hypothesis and the
conclusion and see if that's also true
so let's say it in Reverse so if a
triangle is an obtuse triangle then the
triangle has an angle measure greater
than 90 degrees is that true yes that is
true as well
so what that means is that we can write
this as a by conditional statement and
here's how we're gonna do it we're going
to drop the if and we're going to
replace the then with this phrase if and
only if so here it goes a triangle
an angle measure greater than 90 degrees
if and only if it is an obtuse triangle
okay we got it so let's do a second
example it says a number is rational if
and only if it can be written as a ratio
of two integers okay so just a quick
review in case you don't know about
rational numbers see this word rational
rational just means it can be written as
a ratio meaning a fraction of an integer
divided by another integer okay so for
example 2/3 that's rational because it's
an integer over an integer say for
example square root of 16 that's equal
to 4 which is like 4 over 1 that's a
ratio of an integer over an integer so
let's read this again so they're telling
us it's a biconditional statement see
this if and only if that tells us that
it's true for words and in Reverse so
let's break it down into its original
conditional statement in its original
converse statement okay before we put it
together into this by conditional so how
about first if a number is rational then
it can be written as a ratio of two
integers okay let's do the converse now
if a number can be written as the ratio
of two integers then it is a rational
number so you see how if we're given a
biconditional we know that it's going to
be true for word and the converse I like
to say it like in Reverse backwards but
what we're doing is we're switching the
hypothesis and the conclusion so
remember conditional statements are
if-then statements but when you write a
by conditional you drop it if you place
the venn with if and only if so I hope
this helps you understand how to work
with biconditional statements better
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon